[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اسوا حاله لتفشي وباء الكولر
القاتل في العالم قائمه اليوم في اليمن
امر تؤكده المنظمات الانسانيه والاغاثه
ووليه ويفاقم من هذه الحال الصراع الدائر
في هذا البلد وما ادى اليه من تدمير البنى
التحتيه وحرمان معظم السكان من المياه
النظيفه والصرف الصحي السليم وقد دعت
اليونيسيف ومنظمه الصحه العالميه جميع
الاطراف في اليمن الى انهاء هذا النزاع
المدمر تقرير محمد ابراهيم ونعود بعده
للنقاش حول الوضع الانساني في
اليمن وباء الكوليرا يوشك ان يتفشى في كل
شبر من التراب اليمني ناقوس خطر قرعته
الامم المتحده وهيئات الصحه الدوليه بعد
ان بدا الوباء الخروج عن السيطره
والانتشار في البلاد وازهاق مئات الارواح
200 ال اصابه حتى اليوم واضحى الوباء يقتل
طفلا واحدا كل دقيقه حسب ما اعلنت منظمه
انقذ الاطفال
البريطانيه المنظمه قالت انه في كل يوم
يموت ثلا يمنيا ومن المتوقع ارتفاع
الاصابات الى 300 ال شخص في الاش المقبله
توفي منذ ظهور كارثه الكوليرا نحو 1400
شخص كما تقول منظمه الصحه العالميه ارقام
مرعبه تتحدث عن نفسها وخاصه معدل الاصابه
الذي بلغ 5000 حاله يوميا الامر الذي حدى
بمنظمه الصحه الى اطلاق تحذيرات من زياده
كبيره في الوفيات في الافق المنظور
المنظمه عزت ذلك المشهد الكارثي الى الحرب
التي تشهدها البلاد بين ميليشيا الحوثي
والقوات الحكوميه المدعومه بتحالف عربي
تقوده السعوديه ستيفن اوبراين وكيل الامين
العام للامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه وصف
تفشي الكوليرا في اليمن بانه كارثه من صنع
الانسان وحمل مسؤوليتها جميع الاطراف
المتحاربه وداعميهم الدوليين ويشهد اليمن
شللا في اغلب المستشفيات والمنشات الطبيه
حيث دمر المئات من هذه المستشفيات بسبب
القتال الدائر منذ عامين فضلا عن نقص حاد
في المست زمات الطبيه عوامل عديده ساهمت
في تمدد ال كوليرا الى ان اصبحت اليمن
اخطر حاله يسجلها العالم عن هذا الوباء
لكن السؤال الذي يطرح نفسه في ظل المشهد
اليمني القاتم من هو المسؤول عن انتشار
الوباء بين السكان وصعوبه مواجهته وما هو
دور الحكومه اليمنيه والاطراف المتحاربه
خاصه التحالف العربي المعنيه بالازمه
اليمنيه الذي اخذ على عاتقه حلها سريعا
وزاره الصحه ال تقول ان الفرق الطبيه تعمل
على مدار الساعه في كل المحافظات واعلن عن
مساعدات سعوديه بنحو 760 مليون دولار لكن
هل يكفي ذلك لمواجهه الواقع اليمني البائس
وباء الكوليرا لا شك انه اذا لم يتم تطويق
انتشاره سريعا لن يرحم احدا لا يمنيين ولا
غيرهم في الجوار
النقاشي في الموضوع ينضم الينا من تعز عبد
العزيز المجيدي الكاتب الصحفي اليمني ومن
جناف الدكتور احمد زويين مستشار الطوارئ
الخاص باليمن في منظمه الصحه العالميه
اهلا بكما دكتور احمد اذا بدات معك ما هي
المحافظات او المناطق الاكثر تاثرا بتفشي
وباء الكوليرا في
اليمن بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم المناطق الاكثر تاثرا في اليمن هذا
اليوم هي امانه العاصمه في صنعاء نفسها
الحديده وحجه وعمر
هذه هي المناطق التي اكبر الحالات اكتشفت
فيها لكن لا داعي للتذكير
بان اكثر من 84 85 من المحافظات او
المناطق متاثره هذا يعني انها اكثر من
85% من مجموع الاراضي متاثره بوباء
الكوليرا الحالي عبد العزيز مجيدي كونك
صحفي متواجد على الارض الى اي مدى يرتبط
تفشي الكوليرا في اليمن بالممارسات التي
تتبعها ميليشيا الحوثي
صالح مساء الخير في الواقع هناك ماساه
حقيقيه تتفاقم في محافظه تعز بحسب
الاحصائيات الرسميه هناك اكثر من
17500 حاله اسهال مائي حاد وهناك حتى حتى
اليوم اكثر من 120 حاله وفاه في محافظه
تعز وحدها تتحدث السلطات الصحيه في
المحافظه عن
تاكد الاصابه لحدود 300 حالهما ادى الى
توقف
او تقرير السلطات التوقف عن الاستمرار في
فحص الكثير من العينات لان الوصول الى هذا
الرقم الكبير 300 حاله من مجموع الحالات
التي تم فحصها مخبريا يشير الى
وجود نكبه حقيقيه في البلاد وليس في
محافظه تعز وحدها ساهمت سلطات الميليشيات
خلال الفترات الماضيه من خلال الحصار
المضروب على المدينه
بمفاوضات شار حم الضنك في فترات سابقه
بسبب ا تكدس اطنان القمامه في والمخلفات
في شوارع المدينه من المعروف ان
الميليشيات ا تسيطر على المناطق التي كانت
تمثل مقلبا لهذه القمامه المجموعه من
شوارع ومناطق مدينه تعز وبالتالي الان
اصبح من الصعوبه بمكان الوصول الى هذه
المناطق واصبحت هذه القمامه تتكدس في
الكثير من الاحياء والشوارع رغم وجود بعض
الجهود التي تبذل في هذا الجانب لكن من
غير اسالك عن الجهود بعد قليل لا سما
الجهود الحكوميه دكتور احمد
دكتور احمد ما العائق امام احتواء انتشار
وباء الكور نتحدث عن ارقام مخيفه 300 ال
متوقع في الاشهر المقبله ما العائق امام
احتوائه الامر الاول الذي اود ان اشار
اليه ان الكوليرا انتشر كوباء في يمن
وحوالي عامين من النزاع المسلح تركت البن
تحتيه وخاصه ماتعلق بالصحه وتعقيم المياه
مدمره تماما هذا يعني ان القطاع الصحي فقط
45% منه يعمل بشكل كافي الباقي اما مدمر
او يعمل بشكل جزئي العاملون في قطاع الصحه
لا يتقاضون رواتبهم بشكل كامل وهذا يعني
انهم غير قادرين للتعامل مع وباء ينتشر
بهذه الكثافه وحقيقه ان الوباء انتشر الى
285 مديريه في البلد يجعل من الصعوبه
بمكان لاي منظمه ان تستجيب لمطالبه لهذا
السبب يونسيف وشركائنا الاخرين يعملون ليل
نهار لضمان تقديم الرعايه اللائقه للسكان
راينا من الان تراجعا في في في عدد
الولادات هذا يعني ان الذين يموتون بسبب
الكول
0.8 وهذا هو اقل من هو ما هو متوقع في او
مقبول على المستوى الدولي لهذا السبب نرى
ان جهود منظمه الصحه العالميه واليونيسيف
ووزاره الصحه والشركاء الاخرين اثمرت بعض
النتائج الطيبه لكن ما نسميه بنسبه
الاصابات في صفوف الناس الذين يصابون بهذا
الوباء يزداد لكن هنا هناك تباط قليل نحن
نامل ان يكون
التبا وليس فقط لوجود فتره حضانه للمرض
شكرا شكرا لك دكتور احمد سيد عبد العزيز
باختصار ايضا تحدثنا عن مسؤوليه الحوثي
صالح ماذا عن مسؤوليه الحكومه ما الذي
تقدمه في هذا الصدد لوقف انتشار الوباء في
اليمن من الواضح ان الحكومه الشرعيه ومن
خلفها التحالف سرعتها في الاستجابه
للتحديات الماثله في المحافظه وفي الكثير
من المحافظات المحرره بطيئه للغايه الوباء
يتفاقم بشكل كبير المرافق الصحيه شبه
منهاره الخدمات المتعلقه بشبكه المياه
والصرف الصحي تكاد تكون ايضا منهاره بشكل
تام ليس هناك جهد واضح للعمل بشكل سريع
للاستجابه لهذه التحديات ومواجهه هذا
الوباء على الاقل من اجل التقليل من خطر
الوفيات والاصابات بين السكان ان تحتاج
محافظه تعز على وجه التحديد للكثير من
الدعم العاجل والسريع خصوصا للقطاع الصحي
وقطاع النظافه فهذه القطاعات تتسبب
بالكثير من انتشار تتسبب بشكل كبير
بانتشار الاوبئه وتحديدا وباء الكليره
الذي يتفاقم الان ث يصيب الناس بالذعر
نتحدث الان عن الاف الحالات وهذه الحالات
مرشحه ل التفاقم بشكل اكبر خلال الفترات
المقبله وليس هناك على ما يبدو سوى خم 20%
من الدعم الذي توفر للمحافظه في مقابل ما
يفترض ان يتم من دعم
للمحافظه والواجب توفره خلال المرحله التي
تعيشها الان شكرا لكما في تعز عبد العزيز
المجيدي الكاتب الصحفي اليمني وفي جناف
الدكتور احمد
الزويتينه العالميه شكرا لكم مشاهدينا
الكرام الى اللقاء بامان الله
[موسيقى]
ورعايته
ا